well I canceled a comment on behalf of
Google because you know I think their
Google business executive have very
clear mind about what they doing but I
would only comment that you know I think
when we look at China and also the
opportunities for foreign companies in
China I think we need to take a broader
view and power up the longer view the
media sector where Google is in is a
rather sensitive sector for the Chinese
government for the reasons that I think
everybody understand and so you know I
think it you know it is in a way it is
not unreasonable to see you know the
difference perspective between a company
like Google and the delicate Chinese
government I cannot put a value judgment
on who sprite who is wrong but what what
my view is that that is you know only
one that the data points are within a
broader universe of considerations and
in fact for many companies that I work
with and I talked to many foreign
companies including many American
companies to continue to see tremendous
opportunities in China but also they see
competitive threats coming out from
China so you know companies are not very
busy and sort of saying you know what is
google mean to me companies a thing
saying what does China willing mean to
me in terms of both the opportunities as
well as the threats are the challenges
so I say that you know Google is an
important case because it's highly
visible but at the same time is only one
data points within numerous data points
within the universe of companies doing
business in China or with China
well I think oh you know to what extent
the Chinese we want to adjust the
policies in this area I think it's you
know I offer obviously that's what does
a decision that Johnnie command should
make with respect to Google you know I
think they will look at it from the
business standpoint towards then they
can be successful in China within the
current regulatory context and the fact
the matter is for many of the foreign
Internet companies have been trying you
know to could go into China and try to
compete within in China contacts many of
the foreign Internet companies find that
it's actually pretty challenging because
the local come nocal companies are
actually fairly competitive so so that's
that's a reality that you know you know
businesses of our competition and when
you're facing with strong competition
then you know you need to be careful
about you know what's the next step
should you want to continue to invest
the resources to try to computer along
with the other guys or do you want to
make a withdrawal then you know it's a
decision that every company needs to me
but the Chinese companies are very very
competitive in their own space
you